creator of the River Nile or free veered
and feared aggressive and unpredictable
yet some still call him gift bringer and
even protect her sobic is the ancient
Egyptian crocodile god of the River Nile
his appearance is what makes him so easy
to identify but even that itself
slightly varies sometimes he was shown
as a large crocodile similar to those
found in the River Nile and other times
he appears a human man with the head of
a crocodile he was so Beck's appearance
that made him so terrifying crocodiles
were just one of the many species of
animals found in the River Nile that
were capable of devouring a man over the
years there have been numerous tale was
attempting to explain to us how exactly
the River Nile was formed in some of
these stories the river was created from
the sweat that poured from Cybex body
being able to rule over the River Nile
when considering the amount of dangerous
and aggressive creatures that called the
river home was no easy task but because
sobic was able to do this
he was seen as even more dangerous than
the creatures themselves the River Nile
did also bring with it many positive
aspects it provided fertile soil and
means to grow vegetation essentially
given birth to new life acerbic was
considered to control these waters he
was seen as a fearless protector of the
Nile which often led him to also be an
associated of fertility as well as
crocodiles in the River Nile itself the
God was worshipped by the ancient
Egyptian people because of the gifts he
bought them the gifts of vegetation and
fertility that came of the River Nile
but despite this he was still extremely
feared by the people his reptilian
appearance and the rule of her
environment as harsh as the Nile meant
that cervicals quite often seen as
aggressive and unpredictable his
behavior was often attributed to animal
instinct and along with this instinct
and his association with fertility he
was regarded as a very sexual very
similar to an animal that is unable to
control its urges throughout the years
sobic has been referred to by many names
including Sir Beck so ket Sukkos in
ancient Greece and of course sobic as
we've come to know him by today he was
first mentioned in the Pyramid Texts of
the old kingdom which were widely
regarded as some of the oldest sects to
exist when sobic first made an
appearance it was in the ancient
egyptian city of shed yet the ancient
Greeks referred to this
city as Crocodylus essentially meaning
city of the crocodile or crocodile city
the city of shed yet was part of a
larger region known as phi m and that is
why sobic was given the nickname lord of
phi m as one would expect in the city of
the crocodile so Baek had quite a cult
following there was a large temple built
in his name to honor the God the temple
was home to a crocodile but people
called the son of sobic and it was
worshipped as the manifestation of sobic
it was even adorned with gifts of gold
and gems the crocodile was fed better
than most people within the city with a
diet consisting of luxuries such as meat
wine and milk with honey when the
crocodile died much like the Pharaohs of
Egypt it was mummified and then replaced
by another crocodile who assumed the
role of son of sobic when observing what
took place in the city itself there were
numerous Greek historians who recorded
that anyone who was killed by a
crocodile considered to be the son of
sobic was considered to be divine the
victims would be embalmed and buried in
a sacred coffin and special funeral
rites will be performed by the priests
of the Nile it may seem strange to us
now but some of the ancient Egyptians
kept crocodiles just like house pets
believing that feed in a crocodile would
mean they would receive so bex blessing
despite sobic being worshipped in the
old kingdom it wasn't until the Middle
Kingdom when the influence of sobic
really began to grow during this period
he was often associated with the god
Horus and there are even numerous
depictions of the two gods fused
together the head of a falcon placed on
the body of a crocodile it's also
believed that Horus may have taken the
form of a crocodile when attempting to
retrieve the body parts of Osiris that
set had scattered around the rivers of
Egypt there is a story where the four
sons of Horus were drowning in the River
Nile but sobic appeared and gathered
them all up in a giant net placing the
children back on land now this story
raised a very interesting theory to me
who sobic been considered so
unpredictable and temperamental you
would assume that he saved the children
of Horus because Horus was a god and in
turn saw his children but there is
another story that somewhat changed my
view on the situation when Seth killed
his brother Osiris he disembodied him
and through his body parts in the rivers
of Egypt one morning sobic saw the parts
of Osiris in the Nile and they looked so
appetizing to sobic that he could not
resist and began to eat the pots of us
are
as they floated by sobic was eventually
punished for defiling the God in this
manner by having his tongue removed
which is why when we see crocodiles in
Egyptian mythology they are rarely ever
depicted as having tongues if we compare
the two stories in one so Bakr pays to
show compassion to his fellow gods in
the other he completely disregards them
the way I interpret a difference between
these two stories is that sobic is
constantly described as being very
instinctual and almost primitive and
he's approached to his duties when he
saw the children of horus drowning in
the River Nile I don't think the thought
process involved saving the children of
a god I think so Beck's actions were
purely instinctual in the same way we
see animals to protect the offspring of
other animals or even when pets like
cats and dogs are overprotective of
their owners children to me this
explains why when sobic saw the body
parts of osiris floating in the Nile
he did not care that they once belonged
to a God he saw nothing more than an
afternoon snack by no means am I saying
that sobic possesses the intelligence of
an ordinary crocodile but he's
animalistic nature can often be seen and
these two stories do quite a good job in
showing us exactly that by the time of
the New Kingdom sabich's depiction once
again changed rather than being shown as
fused of Horus he was more commonly
associated with rah himself and once
again the two gods was shown as being
one entity creating the new God known as
so Bakura now to say so Beck's parents
were quite powerful influential gods in
Egyptian mythology is quite an
understatement
his mother was Neath the ancient goddess
of war and his father was set the god of
storms desert in chaos there are
definitely a number of scholars who
would argue that so vex father could
have been a host of other gods his close
association with the god Horus has led
many to believe that he may have played
a role in so bik's creation a theory
that is not quite as common is that his
father was khanoom one of the oldest
Egyptian deities known for his depiction
as a man of the head of Iran khanoom was
considered the original source and God
of the River Nile a connection that he
would share with sobic so Beck's wife
was Renee knew tête goddess of snakes
and often considered a protector of the
harvest despite so bit been associated
of a number of other gods that he could
be considered father to I couldn't
really find anything too definitive
which leads me to believe that he may
have fathered none
Sobek was one of the first Egyptian gods
that I ever had the pleasure of learning
about and he's always been one of my
favorites as a result but I'm not
entirely sure if that's because a
younger me thought the idea of a giant
crocodile God was the best thing ever
looking into sobic in much greater
detail as Ali confirmed that he's still
one of my favorite Egyptian gods
he gives us a very simple but also
complex figure to the ancient Egyptians
he was extremely valued as the protector
of the Nile a source that many depended
on to survive
Sobek being a crocodile one of the
deadliest predators in Egypt meant he
was immensely feared but at the same
time he was also respected and revered
with cities and temples built in his
name there were a number of crocodiles
found mummified in tombs and pyramids
showing us that they were treated in
almost the same vein as the great
Pharaohs of Egypt there are some tales
that depicts Sobek has once been a dark
God mostly because of his association
was set and crocodiles being considered
the messengers of set this sentiment if
it ever existed most likely didn't last
long as sobic became somewhat symbolic
to the Pharaohs of Egypt
so Beck's great strength and power was
thought to represent the Pharaohs own
power they even look towards so back in
times of need believing that he would
give Pharaohs in their armies the
strength and fortitude to overcome all
obstacles as well as protecting them
from evil magic despite sabich's
unpredictable and aggressive nature he
was never really considered evil he was
almost seen as a force of nature
uncontrollable instinctual and
unyielding in his role so Beck's
distinct and iconic appearance means we
still see him in media today influenced
in an appearance in the host of games
that I'm sure many of you will be
familiar with
I hope you guys enjoyed this video on
sobic if you did or you have any
questions then let me know what you
thought in the comments below I'd also
like to thank all my patrons who go that
extra mile to support me it was in fact
them who voted on so back to be the next
video so I hope you guys enjoyed it too
but as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained